the 20 top earning female athletes made
an estimated $226 million in 2023 that's
a 133% drop from 2022 is $258 million
but the decline can be attributed almost
entirely to Serena Williams retirement
and Naomi Osaka's long break from
competition in fact there are plenty of
reasons to view the 2023 ranking with
optimism the median for the top 20 is
now $8.5 million up from $7.3 Million
last year and 16 of the 20 list members
are under 30 suggesting they could have
more earning potential there are also
eight athletes surpassing $10 million
matching last year's record total and
double the number from 2021 here are the
five highest paid female athletes of
2023 at number five Naomi Osaka Osaka
who gave birth to a daughter in July
hasn't played competitive tennis since
September 2022 but is gearing up for a
comeback in Brisbane as a tuneup for the
Australian Open in January in the
meantime she's expanded into new
marketing categories by signing sponsor
deals with Bobby baby formula and kraton
kids and her Media Company hanuma raised
5 million in April as it spun off from
the Spring Hill company at number four
Emma
raducanu raducanu built one of the most
valuable endorsement portfolios in
tennis after she won the 2021 Us open at
18 years old with Brands flocking to a
player they thought could be a star for
years to come since then however she's
dealt with a series of injuries and
illnesses seeing her world ranking fall
to number 299 from a high of number 10
in
2022 at number three Coco golf a grand
slam breakthrough at the US Open in
September could push golf to a new level
as a pitchwoman but she was already
doing just fine on the marketing side
signing this year with Baker Tilly Bose
and UPS widely known as a Marvel
Superhero fan the 19-year-old golf
appeared in an ad for 2023 film the
Marvels and Grace the cover of a limited
edition of an invincible Iron Man comic
book on the court golf is ranked a
career-high number three in singles
after winning four WTA tournaments this
year at number two Eileen goo goo who
was born in San Francisco but represents
China in competition is the rare Olympic
sport athlete whose business doesn't
plummet between games the freestyle
skier and model has long-term
sponsorships all over the globe with
Brands including sportswar maker Anta in
China and Louis Vuitton and Victoria
Secret in the west goo coming off a knee
injury returned to the slopes this
December winning halfpipe events in
China and Colorado in her first World
Cup action in 11 months and at number
one IGA shanteek shanteek capped her big
2023 with a title at the WTA finals and
the yearend number one singles ranking
earning a second straight WTA Player of
the Year award at just 22 she has now
spent 82 weeks at number one and she is
14th on the tours career prize money
list with nearly $25 million off the
court Shante bolstered her endorsement
portfolio this year with visa on shoes
and apparel Oshi sports drinks and
information technology company infosis
on top of four existing Partnerships
shant is only the fourth woman to top
the female athlete earnings ranking
since Forbes introduced the list in 2008
after Naomi Osaka Serena Williams and
Maria
Sharapova